hello this is toasting tomba architected
IBM for data and analytics in the cloud
and today i'm going to talk to you about
server this technology and how it is
applied to big data analytics when we
look at big data in the past decades we
can see that there has been it well
there is a traditional form factor of
big data systems that has been used for
many decades already and as this the
form factor of a data warehouse so this
is a highly integrated system highly
optimized for handling big data queries
big data analytic in a very efficient
manner
nevertheless we had about it around the
year 2000 Hadoop coming up and being
adopted very rapidly and gaining a lot
of popularity in this now widely adopted
in the industry even though it also just
big data analytics so why is that why
Hadoop came up so this is because it
brought in addition to this integrated
system now more openness to the table
more openness in terms of the type of
data that it could handle data formats
bring your own data formats the types of
analytics analytic libraries and
languages that can be supported and also
the flexibility in terms of the hardware
the deployment options that you can have
you can bring a custom hardware even
heterogeneous hardware so that's why I
do basically gained a lot of traction
and is now widely adopted today however
we are seeing a trend that basically
results in a yet another form factor of
doing big data analytics and this trend
is driven by actually one thing that is
happening which is the error the raise
of cloud and another thing that actually
goes hand-in-hand a little bit with the
raise of cloud is the consumption
behavior of many people of end-users to
be more oriented on a sharing economy so
people are using more and more just
write shares instead of just renting
not to speak of buying a car just to get
around or they're going with just Airbnb
just to sleep a night somewhere so this
consumer behavior is also applied now to
IT and what actually this term server
less is is actually exactly this so
server less is in fact the sharing
economy for IT and it is it is enabled
by a cloud and it is in fact the most
consequent usage model of cloud is
serverless
and many of you have heard the term
server less and probably most of you
will associate a thing called function
as a service with serverless many of you
think it's synonymous which is not
exactly true but that's what's basically
many people think of and functions the
service is I have my coat and you need
to run my business logic but I don't
provision dedicated system that you get
at hardware or not it's not even
dedicated software I'm just sending it
to a service say please run it for me
running from me may be that many times
so how to scale out it's all done ad hoc
it's basically hiding the fact that
there are servers
that's why it's called serverless now as
I said this is what many people think of
when they heard room service but service
is more than just function as a service
especially when we now look at pick
again at our domain here which is data
big data and analytics the problem with
big data analytics is that we are
talking about state state has to be kept
data my data has to be kept safely
durable reliably I need to be able to
access at any time when I want it and
that's what these systems provide but
now in the quality of new options we can
actually abstract the storage of data
itself as a cloud service on its own and
that's also what's happening on the
cloud and there is the basically cloud
native storage of object storage
an object's torch is basically
serverless storage because you do not
provision disk volumes do not configure
disk volumes you just bring your data
and the system figures out how to store
it and how to basically also distribute
it and make it highly available and so
on it's highly abstracted you just have
a REST API where you upload and download
your data and you can come with
kilobytes of data and going up to
terabytes of data in the same
organizational unit and the thing about
now why is it turbulence is also that
it's a pay-as-you-go
consumption model you don't just use it
as you go you also to pay-as-you-go
which means you're just paying for the
gigabytes that you're storing at this
point right now and if you store less
you will be paying us in a very elastic
completely seamlessly elastic way now
let me now talk about big data analytics
it's not just about storage of data but
also how can we analyze this data and
process this data and that's exactly
what we are now seeing as well driven by
cloud we're seeing additional services
that aren't available around objects
torch such as sequel as a service or
also it allows you to run SQL basically
on the data object storage and just be
billed for this one SQL depending on how
big the SQL was in terms of how much
data it had to skin and you do not pay
for database that is provisioned and
standing around it's just a single SQL
and that's it and there are other things
that basically play in like for instance
messaging as a service so Kafka as a
service where you're also just paying by
the number of messages that are being
processed and then eventually store to
the object storage so there are a series
of these services basically coming up
and in combination they are providing
this new form factor of a big data and
analytics system that is augmenting and
actually complementing the existing form
factors because even though they are
more established in order they are still
a point for using them because they have
to have sweet spots in terms of
their own performance characteristics
and response time guarantees but on the
other side there may be maybe cost
effectiveness benefits here so depending
of your business model and requirements
you may use this or this or the
combination of those things so I hope
this helps to put in perspective how
serverless plays into big data analytics
and how basically generates a whole new
form factor of big data and analytic
systems thank you very much